tom holland reunites with the russo
brothers for
apple tv's cherry the first project for
apple tv
that people might actually watch has
finally arrived with all the random
images i've seen
of this movie i'm going to assume that
everyone got all the spider-man 3
spider-verse facts
wrong this is the real spider-verse yeah
this is what people have been seeing
shots from that like oh there's so many
peter parkers in this that spider-man in
the mask it's going to be in this
trailer
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm 23 years old and
sometimes i wonder if life was good
that bumper
i'm really happy you're here why is that
because i like you
you're right
[Music]
i joined the army why would you do that
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
dang it's a nightmare
what
one day it'll go quiet i don't imagine
that anyone goes in for a robbery if
they're not in some kind of desperation
i've been having a while now and it's no
secret what my face looks like
one thing about robbing banks is you're
mostly robbing women so the last thing
you want to be is rude
oh god
yeah this looks crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's from wayne isn't she
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare
i might finally use my free apple tv
subscription right
wow that was
crazy this is apple's devil all the time
whoa man that tom hall is something huh
every time he shows up now it's just
like tom holland is here to act
watch as he can portray so many states
of anguish and drama
what is let me i gotta look this up i i
haven't looked anything up i've only
seen like
social media images of this and i i knew
the russo brothers directed it well you
know when mysterio opens up the
multiverse then peter parker is forced
into it
an army medic suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder becomes a
serial bank robber
after an addiction to drugs puts him in
debt
wow i was getting some darren aronofsky
vibes too
yeah there was some very prevalent vibes
throughout and especially now that i'm
hearing about the addiction element and
the kind of the hallucination
getting stuck in your memories it looks
like he's dealing a lot with that level
of trauma the racing thoughts being
caught in the past
i'm really intrigued by this and man
this looks like
this is like oscar-worthy stuff for tom
holland i wish it was coming
out this year so that way it could get
an oscar push
yeah instead of february of next year
whenever the oscars
decided to happen in 2021 but yeah i
mean this looked really
cool but also really heavy and dramatic
at least as this trailer is pitching it
like pulse pounding i love that freeze
frame motif they went with just showing
all these different moments that you
know he lived through all these
different kind of harrowing looking
moments and whatnot i'm curious to see
how like the rest of the movie shapes
around him because i'm almost certain
that like tom holland is gonna rake in
praise for this just because yeah he's
shown especially on the heels of like
devil all the time and everything like
just how caliber
of an actor a performer he is and like
it looks like he's really gonna throw
himself into
the life of this like traumatized
soldier figure and i think it's really
cool that the russo brothers
after coming off of the biggest movie of
all time
you know after coming off of that
they're doing something
that looks very experimental in terms of
what people will probably anticipate for
them to do next
this does feel like it has an
interesting pulse to it i imagine that
it'll probably be a little bit more i
don't know if the word would be
meditative but probably a little bit
more deliberate or slower paced and
maybe what the trailer leads on
i get some taxi driver vibes to it as
well yeah it seems like the kind of
movie that might really spend
time just like sitting with him in his
shoes you know because as
exciting of a trailer as it is as as
like trippy of a trailer
as it is i imagine that underneath it
all the emotional undertones would
probably be some very disturbing
qualities throughout
especially in a tale of addiction yeah
because it's dealing with the tale of
addiction and this guy being a bank
robber and while there's some humor to
be had with it especially when he's
breaking the fourth wall talking to
talking to the audience the narration
and all that i don't think it's gonna
leave you with the feeling of
wow this looks cool i imagine that the
path that
he goes down even with the bank robbery
stuff might be like a cool intriguing
hook
i think ultimately it's going to be like
oh man this is a bad
bad life this guy's living yeah yeah
well who's who's the
who's the actress again oh what's going
to give me guys three hours of sleep
today
wasn't she and wayne she yes she is i
think she's the girl
uh the the girl opposite of wayne yeah
and she's great on that show and it's
cool to see her get like you know the
next bump
up into you know a movie like this where
it seems like she's gonna have
a lot to play that love angle elements
in the way they were handling the
hopping around time was another
aronofsky touch that i especially
got from here i'm really curious to see
how the
visuals in terms of the cinematography
will
reflect whatever current mind state he
has that's another thing i thought was
interesting about the direction of this
trailer was
it seemed like depending on where he
was at what point in his life the movie
was shot
different yeah you know like the maybe
the more he gets
the more trauma he collects and the
further he loses his grip on reality
maybe the more stylized the movie will
become
like the narration part made me wonder
about that too because obviously you
know like it's a fun motif to have the
character breaking the fourth wall and
all that but i can also see potential
for
a very unreliable narrator scenario
given that this looks
super subjective yeah the other times
were two especially i think in like out
of rehab sequence or maybe drug trip
sequences
it looked like they did like a four by
four for i don't know what that frame is
called
or there's even like some of these shots
looked like hey they had a little bit of
like a
fish eye to really give you like that's
another thing that kind of reminded me
like you said of darren aronofsky where
it's like that sort of
you're it's super wide and you're just
there for
all of the nitty gritty ugliness and
harshness of it you know and i'm also
wondering about this concept of time
especially because
it's honing so much in on this
character's trauma one thing with
characters who are caught in their own
traumatic state is the last thing they
are is in the present moment
people in life a lot of the times we're
either caught in the past or
worried about the future and at first i
was a little bit confused
is it gonna be one of those videos where
he's like jumping through parallel lives
and universes
seriously that's where my mind was going
like i'm a little confused at first
i had to look up the imdb this concept
of time of like
also being caught up in the regrets i
don't know they have the time in a
bottle song
yeah playing over so it seems like time
in and of itself will play some
pivotal role and i mean even maybe in
just a super immediate way because it
seems like this guy's to be
either spending his time like whacked
out on drugs or
doing some kind of harrowing operation
to work that's what i mean
like either those kind of elements of
doing
like a bank robbery or getting drugs a
lot of times people who suffer with
trauma by doing those things
puts them in the moment yeah they're in
the moment finally getting that high
that rush
so yeah the crazy direction seems like
it's going to fluctuate depending on
whatever
the main character tom holland is
representing so yeah this looks like a
real directing and
acting awesome duo let's do it like if
darren aronofsky and danny boyle crashed
into each other danny boyle
is the that's the freaking director i
was like damn what director is it that
i'm not
citing that is certainly coming to mind
yeah
it has that look of some of those like
smaller movies oh yeah no there's like a
train spotting vibe
yeah yeah spotting that other one with
james mcavoy like not
uh that other one i know you're talking
about i forgot
all right guys well damn this was this
was surprising
interesting yeah what'd you guys think
of the trailer leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button
catch you guys soon
[Music]